WIRE AND DRYING A FEW THING OUT,
YOU KNOW, THIS COULD BE A MATTER
OF WEEKS, DEPENDING HOW
EXTENSIVE THE DAMAGE IS ON THE
WEST COAST.
>> DAVID REUTER, THANK YOU FOR
EXPLAINING THE SITUATION TO US.
WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK IN THE
DAYS AHEAD.
>> THANK YOU, JOHN.
>> BRIANNA.
>> BERMAN, I THINK ONE OF THE
MOST ARRESTING IMAGES THAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THIS ROOF OF AN
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT AT A PORT
CHARLOTTE HOSPITAL WITH AROUND
160 PATIENTS HAVING BLOWN OFF,
AS HURRICANE IAN WAS POUNDING
FLORIDA.
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO
INSIDE THE ICU.
THE ENTIRE FLOOR COVERED WITH
WATER.
THE STAIRWELL LOOKING LIKE A
WATERFALL.
WE ARE TOLD THAT NO ONE WAS ABLE
TO EVACUATE THE HOSPITAL LAST
NIGHT.
SO, OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS
INTERRUPTING SOME OF THE CARE
THAT PATIENTS HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING THERE.
JOINING US NOW WITH AN UPDATE WE
HAVE INTERNAL MEDICAL SPECIAL
DR. BODINE.
DOCTOR, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
FROM THE RELATIVE DRY, YOU CAN
TELL US HOW THE PATIENTS ARE
DOING AND THE LIFE AND CONDITION
OF PATIENTS IN THE HOSPITAL?
>> LUCKILY, EVERYBODY WAS SUPER
FANTASTIC, AND VERY QUICKLY, WE
GOT PEOPLE OUT OF THE ICU.
THE PROBLEM ENDED UP BEING THAT
THE WATER RUSHED DOWN THE
STAIRWELL YOU THAT SEE THERE AND
ON TO OTHER FLOORS.
FIRST, WE INITIALLY HAD TO
EVACUATE PEOPLE OUT OF THE ICU
AND ABLE TO GET PEOPLE INTO
ESSENTIALLY THE POST RECOVERY
AREA WHERE THEY COULD HANDLE THE
PATIENTS.
AFTER THAT, THOUGH, WE STARTED
TO SEE THE WATER WAS GOING
EVERYWHERE.
SO, WE HAD TO GET A LOT OF OUR
PATIENTS OUT OF THE ROOMS AND
INTO THE HALLWAYS.
I'VE BEEN UP SINCE 2:30 THIS
MORNING ROUNDING -- WE'RE TRYING
TO GET EVERYBODY, LUCKILY.
EVERYBODY IS DOING GOOD.
ACTUALLY, SURPRISINGLY IN DECENT
SPIRITS BECAUSE THEY CAN SEE
WE'RE TRYING THE BEST WE CAN
WITH WHAT WE HAVE.
AND THE STAFF IS SUPER
FANTASTIC.
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN IN-HOUSE NOW
FOR THE LAST 48 HOURS PRETTY
MUCH.
NONE OF US HAVE GONE HOME YET.
WE'VE ALL SLEPT HERE.
TAKEN TURNS FOR A FEW HOURS HERE
AND THERE.
OUR PLAN IS TO TRY TO GET THESE
PATIENTS OUT THIS MORNING,
OBVIOUSLY.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO
EVACUATE THEM THIS MORNING.
YOU CANNOT BE IN THESE
CONDITIONS FOR VERY LONG.
THE PICTURES ARE JUST TERRIBLE
HERE.
TELL US WHAT IT WAS LIKE GOING
THROUGH THE STORM.
I MEAN, YOU DESCRIBED MOVING
FROM ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER.
AND THEN THE WATERFALL EFFECT OF
THIS WATER.
WERE YOU WORRIED THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO BE A SITUATION WHERE
YOU COULDN'T FIND REFUGE IN
HALLWAYS AND KEEP THIS AT BAY?
>> YES AND NO.
I MEAN, LUCKILY, PATIENTS ARE IN
BEDS SO EVEN THOUGH TO THIS
MOMENT, WE STILL HAVE WATER IN
THE HALLWAYS THAT WE'RE SLOSHING
THROUGH, THE PATIENTS ARE
OBVIOUSLY ELEVATED IN THEIR
BEDS.
SO LUCKILY, THE PATIENTS ARE
SAFE IN TERMS OF THAT.
WE ALSO HAVE ONE WING OF THE
HOSPITAL THAT IS DRY, THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TRIPLE UP SOME
PATIENTS INTO ROOMS SO THAT AS
MANY ARE THERE AS POSSIBLE.
BUT, I'D SAY, IT WAS CHAOTIC,
BUT I HAVE TO SAY, I'M VERY
PROUD OF EVERYBODY HERE WHO HAS
BEEN WORKING HERE.
IT WAS A L